it's your girl and right now currently I
am at the trash taste booth and there is
quite a lot of people here I want to ask
one of them who do they think is the
best wife let's go find some unlucky
victim hi my guys who do you think is
the best wife personally I'm a big fan
of zero two that's kind of sad who do
you think is the best waifu like ever
yeah you know the the cat girl from
morogati it's your best waifu but you
don't even remember her name
should care what people say is the best
waifu that's the first decent answer
I've heard all day who is the best waifu
to exist you're from spyx family you
know a little popular answer kind of
like normish but you know what mine's a
little unpopular but it's KO Benny from
chainsaw man